bientôt diffusés en hd sont surtout le
jardin direct mais quinze jours du mika
joue un petit bébé bien dodues voilà
comme qui montrent son cul très mal poli
très belle poule à l'équipe fabrizia un
bébé chat va la faire là où je vais mais
plus lourd du monde est en fait ce
métier parce les dessous dessus en
bouffant n'importe quoi en faisant que
des bêtises un vrai fdp et moi je vois
l'empêcher de se tuer 1 et vu je suis un
très bon papa je joue avec les jouets de
monfils rien ta gueule oui en direct aux
essais vont bientôt tu fais quoi tu fais
quoi et tu fais partie tiens je te casse
le crâne avec bien aux bleus ont fait on
met pas des faits c'est dans la famille
des eaux jarrah haut mais découvre au tu
fais quoi
j'ai fais quoi ces grands bois pascal
fils s'est pas forcé c'est à la fois de
lâcher pour laver les vitres
ol a tout bu je dois cacher les piles un
bruit de chiffres c'est n'importe quoi
aux germes à saint barth au jeu porte
tabasser c'est comme ça qu'on ait du
clochard nous a dit qu'elle hockey
martin bea auquel chais monnet
approchait non d'accroître j'ai un
marteau ok ok je te voler le marteau non
je peux pas si c'est bon j'ai les 2 g
les deux géants fourchette côté dans le
bartos mandaté vers mon gars tu
commences à être très très mal faut que
j'appelle le 911 oh non j'ai sauté de là
c'est trop facile de mourir quand l
enfant natalie choquette casadesus de
cash fait comme si j'étais pas ton père
et que c'est un inconnu qui joue du
piano
dis moi si tu apprécies cette douce
musique / mal dans ta gueule matin je
veux car elle a une fille zoé pour tout
y descend ça marche
ok ok ok fiston j'arrive avec bâle a
joué pas cool c'est que tu es en train
de faire des conneries là où tu fais
quoi petit foetus
regardez son petit corps de lachenaie
avancé [ __ ] mais ils répondirent l
ucao charles à 19 ans débarque fils
thomas dans le panier pour voir
tu vas aller dedans vas-y attendait à
l'envers merde en du groupe couach au
chômage je n'arrive pas et on n'a pas
décidé
tu pas des loubards au fiston aller aux
chars ils font attention à leur alors
prochain festo je vais faire du surf sur
toi dans les marches mon gars non on va
pas là déjà tu vas te cacher sous cette
table basse
je te croyais pas quand j'ai gagné j'ai
gagné ta peau le temps de mourir
as tu fais quoi telle bataille
prudemment ce n'est qu'à ces détergents
teinte à la poubelle et procédé il ya
tout qui par la route mais ça je suis un
bébé maudite
ben je mange des papiers pourquoi non
mais qu en tant que maire j'ai bel arrêt
des bagues à celle qui pouvait le papa
savez l'herbe et bas restera fermé la
torche fait quoi mais tais-toi séditieux
et pour couronner le tout l espace et du
fait que ce cas tu n'as pas entrer dans
les câblages vais pas au oui papa j'ai
envie de cuir comme une bonne dinde
toyota ils sont pas les coups ils vous
regardent salle éclate genre mais la
chaleur j'ai froid aux yeux
quelle attraction formidable j'ai eu des
pilules gd pilule amère mais je suis con
les pilules en fait ça me soigne un ange
est débile on était dans la salle de
bain oh mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ah non fin mai elle m'a vu moi je chante
je valais dans la chambre il s'y cache
un terrible secret papa tous les
mouchoirs que tu utilise à des fins
personnelles je vais les trouver les
manger ta vie c'était leur auto mignon
du bébé ça papa papa j'ai les mains sur
un objet bizarre je sais pas trop quoi
en faire jouer pour le crunch au 15 mai
théo est prêt dans mon petit arrière je
m'étais qu'est ce que c'est que ça papa
tu m'expliques office et une petite
corde à sauter suffit de sauter séquencé
pour enfants à croquer hop là 21 c'est
génial
un peu grosse quand même pour une corde
à sauter oui mais justement faut faire
mais bercy c'est assez pour faire des
sons plus haut oui à et avait bien
souple pour
au fiston tout devient pianiste
donc c'est une diversion d'accord mais
pistons tu marches à l'heure
qu'est ce que tu veux devenir fiston jeu
mangeurs de papier regarde on n'a pas
mangé de papier non mais ça c'est des
lions des études ça amène homme suffit
d'être majeur jeu comme ça tape au pied
aux noms soumis à tuchan pas humoriste
listons meshrep hugo chavez non gitans
galère si je faisais un petit clin
d'oeil aux gens qu'un piston vas-y tu
montes sur l'assiette ça fait une belle
d'inde allez va sur l'assiette cba plus
tôt c'est bien tu as l'air bien en plus
dans ton pour aller aux fermes se
fourrer tu dégages
allez les stores tu casses te font face
au tchèque face à l'entente darty pas la
pochette de puylaurens je te fuis non tu
me rejoins fourchette 1 non au
médicament au fiston tu vas prendre la
pilule tew fiston je m'enfuis pas
pourquoi la porte est ouverte
la question prend des pilules chat et
fourre tout était vraiment temps que dit
tiens regarde ça c'est hyper dangereux
pour la santé
prolait oui oui je suis allé manger fait
pas semblant fête rassemblant petit
homme nu à l'écurie coup mal et le mec
il est mort quoi ou té papa c'est vrai
[ __ ] avec la fourchette je pense que
tu peux te donner du coup dû en fait
ah ouais j'suis vraiment dire est que
maintenant alors un bâtard oui la
verrouiller de le calculer est
maintenant tu vas prendre tes petites
pilules et voilà d'abord
mais comment tu as fait pour tout perdre
et oui d'accord gates brigitte et la
silla au lac n'empêchera pas le coeur
j'appuierai bin jassem autant que toi
papa est de toucher si vous tombez
hausse tangible dès mon retour je touche
pas les boutons va pas on n'a pas de
sens d'acheter du monde il a acheté un
sauna papa et je vais régler ton acte
nec tous les boutons laval et je peux
plus sortir à temps qui m'est annoncé un
miroir mais ces mecs c'est nul n'était
même pas d'accord je vais assister à une
apparition paranormal make the pack du
vélo qu'on ne voyait [ __ ] non non
c'est pas de bosse en bosse pas de
l'ours tu veux te lave et inquiète pas
basile à moi papa là - laisse couler
l'eau pas page et en plus il faut laver
jumbo steuplé baba mais je me lavais
avec toi d'accord le père vraiment
chelou au nom
au québec nous a tous fait un clip
chorégraphié en live d'accord veston le
tapis cette visite il aimait manger
cette glaçante tu sais tu sais mais ça
s'appelle un suicide intervienne le
menton fait ce que j'ai fait une bêtise
il prend un marteau ils cassent une
table basse mais jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire d'humanité bonne chance hier
pas céder aux surcoûts zurda dit mais
qui est ton papa mais ça vaut rien la
vidéo n'était pas aimé ça vous a plu bon
c'est un jeu en alpha d'alpha d'une bêta
d'une alfa pas ce mytho prochaine de et
savoir garder portez vous bien et que
tout le monde
bish il a fait